i was wondering how do you go about
picking i know your answer might be you
know maybe follow the thing that you're
most passionate about but how do you
find something that you're most
passionate about in terms of wanting to
start
a future startup yeah so passion okay so
my answers on these things is usually
not
uh find out what you're most passionate
about uh that's actually a very
unimaginative answer and that's the
really old answer where it's like people
will either say you know your parents
will say do what's practical and all the
books will say do what you love i don't
think either is actually quite correct
uh i think the the way that i like to
phrase it which is uh nuanced and it's
important to get the whole thing is
you want to find what
feels like play to you
but
looks like work to others so both of
those are true both of those have to be
simultaneously true
so feels like play to you is the what
you're passionate about part so you'll
naturally be good at it you're into it
you're curious about it you enjoy doing
it
but looks like work to others that is
equally important that means that it has
in society that thing is seen as a work
by other people and therefore it is
likely to have some value so you want to
find the intersection of those two and
that's not easy i'm not saying you're
necessarily going to find it trivially
nor that you're going to find it you
know on a time on a timeline when you're
in college one of the false dichotomies
of college is this idea that you're
expected to decide on your career that
you're going to do for the next 10 20 50
100 years whatever you know through path
during this very short couple of years
stint
and unfortunately i think we lock people
into lifetimes of drudgery where they
basically say well i'm going to go be a
lawyer they go to law school now they're
locked into law whether they love the
law or not or the practice of law or not
or investment banking or medicine or
what have you these are straight jackets
it's like too early especially now his
careers have gotten longer and people
live longer getting them to commit for
like their entire lives based on these
short stints too much so
i would say you know especially at your
age
and given that you're in computers uh
and you're basically coding don't
overthink it just build things just
build whatever you feel like build toys
build apps for yourself
just do whatever you enjoy now to most
people
to most people sitting in front of a
computer and writing code looks like
work so almost anything you do in front
of a computer especially with code that
is fun to you that feels like play to
you uh satisfies kind of the criteria so
i would say just code for fun if you
code for fun you will eventually find
your way to something you're passionate
about and that you can make money in now
i think that's somewhat unique to you
because a you're the luxury of time
because you're very young even though i
know in college they pressure you and it
may feel like you don't have that luxury
time you really do have the luxury of
time
and the second reason is because you're
coding if you're coding in computer
science and cognitive science you're
good at using the tool that is you know
the most powerful tool ever invest
invented by humanity that gives you
permissionless leverage so you're
actually way ahead of the curve
unfortunately most people
when they ask these kinds of questions
most of people when they ask them my
answer starts with some variant of learn
to code which i hate to say it because i
don't want to be glib i know it's not an
easy thing to do but at the same time
it's like if you were you know alive
when mo when literacy was first getting
widespread and you were not literate you
know someone who really had your best
interest at heart would tell you hey go
learn to read and write it's just too
important to not do it so in the same
way when you know numeracy was becoming
more widespread they would say hey go
become good at mathematics now literacy
and numeracy are prerequisites for
programming so now i can just say go
program because it means you have to be
illiterate you have to be enumerate and
you have to be facile with the best pool
that we've ever invented where you can
permissionlessly create and extract
leverage so
i think you're already most of the way
there you just need to code for fun
so let's jump right in the first story i
want to return to steve jobs
okay but now i want to rewind time
back a little further let's say you had
a time machine and you could go back to
meet a young steve jobs
probably the first thing you would do is
go buy apple stock but let's say you go
back even earlier than that in a high
school age steve jobs the biographical
sources we have today suggested if you
talk to a young steve jobs you would not
come away with the idea that he was
passionate about building a technology
company
not have at that point in his life a
passion for changing the world through
technology right so steve jobs did not
go to berkeley to study electrical
engineering which is what you would have
done in that time in that place if you
were really passionate about electronics
and he didn't go to stanford or ucla to
study business which is probably what
you would have done in that time in that
place
if you're very passionate about
entrepreneurship and business
he instead went to reed college a
liberal arts school up in oregon he
studied history studied dance
pretty soon afterwards he dropped out
and hung out on campus walking around
barefoot experimenting with sort of
extreme diets bumming free meals from
the hare krishna temple
eventually he got fed up with being
completely destitute came back to
california took a night shift job at
atari and that was very specific because
he wanted flexibility and not too much
responsibility
and he began to study eastern mysticism
way more seriously that had just arrived
on the shores of the west coast in this
period
he went on a mendicant's journey to
india in this point
months long minikin's turning to india
came back started the study seriously at
the los altos zen center and began to
spend an increasing amount of time in
the all one commune upstate
so the point of this is that this is a
portrait of someone
who is seeking
the classic example of someone
young
early in their life trying to figure out
what life's about what they want to do
with their life
a lot of us go through this stage but
jobs being jobs couldn't just read
kerouac he had to actually go to india
and spend three months because he's
intense about everything he does but
he's basically reflecting something that
a lot of us went through ourselves
trying to understand what are what are
we doing here what's the meaning of life
he was in a seeking mode
but what's clear about that is this was
certainly not someone with a crystal
clear vision of i am passionate about
starting a technology company and i'm
going to find a way to do that one way
or the other
it was not at all his mind frame in the
years leading up to apple computer so
apple computer how did it come about
i think the right word is that
him and was stumbled into the
opportunity
wallace had been working on a circuit
board for what was essentially the apple
one
steve jobs had recently met paul tyrell
who had one of the first computer stores
in the world up in mountain view
so jobs came back and said look this
circuit board was popular at the
homebrew computing club i want to sell
you 50 so you can sell it to the
hobbyist around here an earlier
biographer of jobs jeffrey young
actually crunched numbers and they're
looking to make around a thousand to two
thousand dollar profit
off of that exchange
and i thought that number was low so i
even got back in touch with paul terrell
recently and he confirmed the details of
it yeah he came in to sell 50 of these
things to hobbyist basically it was a
small time transaction they had done
several other
quick money making schemes like this
before
but paul terrell said the jobs
i don't want to buy circuit boards i
want to buy fully assembled computers
paul terrell had the vision that there
was going to be a market for computers
as appliances that this was coming
and jobs to his credit
understood that opportunity when he saw
it
and he went at it full out you know he
did some trickiness cod ordering he
didn't have money but he got those
together and apple computer was
eventually born out of that
so there's a couple lessons to draw from
that story the first lesson is the path
the passion is often way more
complicated
than simply figuring out in advance this
is what i want to do and then going out
and doing it
so when we looked at job story there he
did not have a pre-existing passion to
go start a technology company
his path in the apple computer and the
the passion he had for that company was
more complicated than him figuring out
in advance what he wanted to do
so if you go out and study people like
jobs
who ended up loving their work and i
studied this extensively researching the
book you find that that more complicated
path is more the rule than the exception
that it's actually very rare to find
someone who really did have clarity
about what they were passionate about in
advance and then
went after it
to form their career that ended up being
a real source of satisfaction the paths
there are often way more
complicated
sort of one of my favorite quotes about
this is from the
npr host
ira glass this american life host who's
someone who loves his work and there's
this great interview online where some
college students come to glass to ask
him how do we build a career like yours
and he says there's this idea in the
movie that you should follow your dreams
i don't buy that he starts talking for a
while about how you have to force skills
to come and is really hard and when he
sees their faces fall he finally says
guys i see you trying to figure this all
out in the abstract and i think that's
your tragic mistake
so i like the way glass put it the idea
that you can figure out in the abstract
what you're supposed to do with your
career is not just a mistake but it's a
tragic mistake
[Music]
and i think we all sort of feel that
right i mean this notion that if you
think that you can figure out in advance
what you're supposed to do well what
happens when you don't have that clear
passion what's confusion it's anxiety
it's chronic job hopping it's
reading too many blogs
spending too much time on the four hour
work week right you know what i mean
this is what happens if you get too
caught up in this notion that with one
grand gesture you can be loving your
life next week
okay so that's the first lesson to draw
from that story the path to passion in
reality when you really study it is
often way more complicated than what
that advice tells us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you